actor will smith is once again
apologizing to chris rock for slapping
him during the academy awards
smith stormed on stage during the awards
ceremony in slap rock after the comedian
made a joke about smith's wife the
incident was seen by nearly 17 million
people watching live and countless more
as the attack was replayed on television
and online for days afterwards here's
vladimir gutier
my behavior
was
unacceptable in a nearly six-minute
instagram video actor will smith again
apologized to chris rock for slapping
him after the comedian made a g.i jane
joke about his wife jada pinkett smith's
baldness
i've reached out to
chris and the mesh the message that came
back is that
he's not ready to talk
so i will say to you chris
i
apologize
to you smith who later won a best actor
oscar that night also explained why he
did not apologize to rock when he
returned to the stage i was fogged out
by that point smith went on to resign
his membership in the academy and was
banned from the oscars for 10 years rock
has yet to respond publicly but
reportedly told a stand-up audience
recently that after the slap he shook it
off and went back to work
i'm not a victim rock said i don't go to
the hospital for a paper cut
smith said he was doing personal work to
address his behavior
i am
deeply remorseful
and i'm trying to be remorseful without
being ashamed of myself
right i'm a human
and
i made
a mistake
while acknowledging the hurt and pain
caused by that mistake smith says he
remains deeply devoted and committed to
putting light and love in the world
for cbs saturday morning vladimir gutier
new york
i know he also apologized to the others
that were there you think of questlove
who had to go and accept his award right
after i hope that smith has individual
acknowledgement with those people
because it was those moments too that
were really stolen absolutely i was i
was sitting right next to the aisle that
quest love walked through and he said
how
do i follow that right right what am i
gonna say as he was walking to accept
his award and it's just you don't get
that moment back you don't get the
moment back and um
it's just unfortunate it's unfortunate
it happened and i still don't understand
why it doesn't sound like will and chris
will be sharing beers anytime this is
true no